everyone thank you for being to this
workshop as i will give with a Sebastian
Ballentine that is that is here so the
title of the workshop is a building
smack application that learn mainly will
build smart application and a bit of
application that learn as well so
there's really two things that's
multiplication things that can take
natural language input that can use our
built-in capabilities in machine
learning and then some application that
you will use the learning function of
Mathematica to to create a an
application and in Indiana my
demonstrator application that actually
learns as it goes is in on the cloud but
I think that for one hour workshop may
be a bit how to code that yourself so
this I will just demonstrate and what we
decided to do is to have a bunch of
exercise so I don't know five six
exercise something like this and a
simple project and as we want it to have
as much fun as you we actually did not
complete this project so we'll see how
it goes but it should it should I mean
we hope it should work we can say take
that as a challenge so I think the idea
is that I I give you so the so the goal
to challenge and and you can try working
on it and as it goes maybe we can you
know pass by and give more and more
elements to help you and and in the end
we just show how you could do it I mean
one way to do it because you know we as
a we ended in the same boat as you here
we haven't done them okay so the first
one would be to create web app that if
you give the name of a city in a natural
language input it shows you the
population of the city all right so you
have to figure out yourself how you
could do that look in the documentation
how do we do a web app how do we
you know go from natural language input
to a symbolic representation of this
input and right let's go so an example
would be if I say if i type Paris it
would actually give me the population
and so so if you int you probably have
to do a form function which is something
to deploy I mean when you have a warm
language code you can use a form
function to give an input and and this
input can be interpreted this function
as be done a drag the backbone of this
function is interpreter which is a tool
that have values type and you can
interpret countries street address
animals all sorts of things including
city and if there's best internet there
would be a problem does everyone has
internet oh good that's a good thing to
do a workshop about building application
where application without internet all
right and the second tip is to use Club
deploy which is a key function to deploy
your phone language into into the cloud
okay all right so did you did you guys
have a solution you have something that
works some of you maybe we can start
giving some element so okay so you have
to use a form function and let's see how
form function works so we go in the
documentation let me put that bigger and
if you look at the specification here
like the most basic one literally on top
as to two arguments the first one is a
foam specification and second one is a
function so the form plication we can
look at an example and actually it's I
mean it's not the perfect example but
yeah you have a list and each element of
this list correspond to one field so
let's copy that one I think it's always
a good idea to it's quite classic boon
documentation copy an example and then
you modify it and if I do that it
creates a form that as ok to to feel we
just want one field and what this means
is that on the on the right part of the
rule it mean that the input would be
interpreted as a string and on the left
part is the name of the input that you
can see there so then you can use this
name uses this syntax so this is a pure
function sorry first it's a pure
function that will so f will act on all
you call that ash first right so if I
submit I can try it you should return f
of this ok so that's here we're going to
put our function so the first thing to
chain is that is not a string we want
it's actually a city
so now the interpretation will be done
automatically if I put something it will
interpret the city and then we want to
do something on this city so instead of
deploying right now i'm going to try
things with interpreter this really
what's underneath the phone function so
if i do interpreter city and i type
Paris we'll see how it works i hope i
have actually maybe myself I yeah I've
internet internet and you know what I
will because I problem with entities
along Y and and if you do that it should
output an entity so it's our way to
representing all this symbolically all
this concept so this is a concept of
Paris the city it's well defined and
then we can ask ok what kind of
properties can we ask to sit to Paris so
with that properties and you have a
bunch of properties and in these
properties you can find city population
I guess only population might work as
well right I mean know exactly its
entity property CT so this is just a
display this is orange stuff the code
underneath is auntie T property first
argument City sole argument population
and that's the way that we kind of
arvest all the knowledge that is in the
Wolfram language that comes from what
from alpha originally that you know
they'd be a lot of curators that put all
these all these data and and so instead
of properties here I can just put city
population and it i put city population
ok so let's do the function now that
output city population actually it's
quite direct so it will just be first
city population ok it takes the city yes
quality population and i have the form
and i can actually try it offline if i
do Paris it should return the population
it worked offline and now let's deploy
it so
all right what is it worth okay and so I
just do cloud deploy okay my computer
lags lots oh hey t what's happening this
is very weird let me
okay so you do club deploy and it will
output a URL on which you can go so okay
I've no idea what's going on if I'm
going to quit the colonel okay that's
always a better always embarrassing but
this happens
alright so the claddagh poll we create a
website ok a web web page and you can go
on this web page and runs a function so
okay let's try again no it doesn't have
the colonel it's actually super slow
still ok I'm going to restart what
really
the same thing at the same time ok ok
let's i'm going to i'm going to i don't
think I mean we was at the band with me
was just uh I don't know my computer to
just get crazy um here we go all right
okay that's much better so I do the form
blue jean i mix okay i hope that oh it's
still very what's going on okay this is
a display that that's a problem oh good
you have to tell that to Carol or
barbieri in infineon the cat though okay
yeah okay okay let's do this oh now it's
aa good okay it's back to normal okay
all right and now I can clear deploy
this form and and I've you al and I can
click on it and and to test this this
website and one thing that you should do
I mean not you should do it it's often
to put permission to public I mean this
is to allow everybody to use your your
URL which when it has a name like that
you pretty save that you know they won't
ruin your cloud credits but it's useful
because sometimes you want to try to
another computer that when you're not
connected to the cloud and and your
rides the network is pretty bad okay
next year we have to do workshop in the
place with a network is good because
workshop needs internet okay first and
now okay what do we try a Chicago right
yeah no I'm not that do I spell Chicago
right you mean you see the small spike
spike is because it's a smartphone
it's because it interprets a type that
is not a string or a number like
something a bit more a bit more
fantasies there's a little spiky here
and and it should output the results can
the normal network it goes fast you have
to look in the properties I don't know
the properties but they may be some some
properties that just take the the entire
area and so on and and okay that's
between it so actually it should return
a quantity because it should return a
Wolfram language thing and the way to
okay I'm I'm very sorry it's very
annoying that why doesn't it written
anything okay so let's try let's try
something so if with a third argument
form function this will tell the format
that it will be converted so it will be
exported to the web page and so maybe
there was a problem with the format it
was exporting it will try again also i
think is just the internet to work so
here it should actually display the
quantity in an image and okay you go you
have the result on top unless you see
are you okay that was a the result so it
rasterized so expression and you put it
in the website so 2.8 million people
okay let's let's move on we have some
more exciting ones maybe this one is not
as exciting as a Western was telling me
so anyway we can do it quickly it's a
how to do tech natural along you know
it's no I mean it no it is interesting
so it's another way to input natural
language you know that allows to input a
bit more complex natural language and
just an interpreter type which is just
like you put a city you put a country
you put whatever here you can actually
put a sentence and and we have to
to interpret a sentence and and that's
actually the same tool made very similar
that are used for more from alpha so the
question is create a function that
multiplies to number when you gave this
this this number in natural language for
example you say multiply three and four
like that and this should work okay and
to be sample let's always use this way
like multiply first number and another
number and to what is OS to em and
grammar okay and you should look at the
function grammar apply to do that and so
Ellie 23 minutes and i will do it to go
to the a bit more exciting examples
okay if you will do it because as soon
as you go to Quogue reply so for example
its first example is is the same so
let's call it multiplication but then it
we will try to understand what what's in
this example okay so its judys grammar
rules grammar rules define some kind of
pattern on the natural language okay
such as you know your pattern for
Wolfram language expression this is some
some pattern for natural language and
here says fixed order so it just mean
that the patterns you cannot actually
you know put them in any order you want
and the first word has to be ad but as
we used to be multiplied okay the second
word the second token will be
interpreted as a semantic number so we
choose interpreter again like all these
things on the under you know on the
bottom there's always interpreter so it
will interpret this token at a semantic
number okay then it has to ever end in a
sentence and then the second number will
be again interpreted as a semantic
number and then this operation will
perform so as it's eight times B and you
have to cloud deploy that and
fortunately grammar rule doesn't work if
you don't have deploy it and and then
you have to use grammar apply so you
have a cloud object and you apply you
you use grammar apply on this cloud
object with whatever you you want to do
so for example what you say multiply 7
and 12 in 123 okay and let's say
probably worked I guess 7 times 10 23 is
that and I mean put seven times three
and everybody will agree with me it's
slow computing it's a slow computation
but mm-hmm ok so this use ok 21 ok
network so yes these things that are
useful for you to define you know when
you when you're in a small set of
sentence you know like for some when you
control your house stuff like that you
always say the same things you know turn
the heater on turn the heater at this
temperature turn the oven on turn the
light of the kids whatever and this you
can put a bunch of rule it won't be that
long and it will do the job and when you
add it with speech to text that let
Sebastian is working on right now it
will allow you to have you know put a
small Raspberry Pi in your in your home
and then you can just pick and things
happens and so sort of smashing in the
world is useful and actually that's how
water Marfa is doing so it gives you an
idea of how it can extend to more
complicated things ok let's do something
more fun now so the idea here is you
have to do a web application that finds
what among the famous person of our
world that we you know all you know love
and care for which one is is you look
like ok which is your famous
doppelganger so you have to find that
and you have to Crane everything does
that and then a displays a picture of
you a picture of the doppelganger and
the name of the doppelganger and then
you have to try it on your phone that's
the task
so I mean I have to give you one int is
that to find which is your doppelganger
you have to use a built-in classifier
notable person otherwise i guess to be
hard to find documentation and the
second arguments you put your image any
good finds you should find
and by the way if you manage to do this
application good thing it can become
viral just breathe to your Facebook
friend and they are sharing and you're
like oh I look like he is so hot and you
know I tried it doesn't work for me
sorry I'm either many Pacquiao or some
guidance on TV show
yes that's a very very good point this
lead to wait because the URL I like this
so it's two way to break your phone
either you email it to you or I know in
some way or you use URL shorten indeed
and I think you can put that directly on
the cloud object actually if we work as
well it can either be a string that
represent URL or the cloud object and
any Twitter have a much tinier URL you
can type after
so yeah if you try it on your computer
you should be able to do current image
although i think if you have linux
sometimes currently measures and work I
never works okay but a new phone it
should always work because it will ask
you to take a picture yes the first time
you use it on your computer it will be
long it's true because it will download
so it's a dip in your network that
there's a job for recognizing the famous
person and it's like 50 megabytes rights
version so it may take a bit but only
the first time but in the cloud that
should already all already be loaded so
hmm should yeah I don't know we'll see
okay it works in the cloud
ah can see that oh we should have done
something when everybody could send the
results and do a display of everyone but
anyway yeah yeah yeah yeah if you do a
M&M so by the way if you do control
equal that's a way to get entity and
let's let's and if you look at the
properties of M&M okay it doesn't right
it's pretty bad what does it work
all right I don't know anyway in the
property you have gender so you can ask
the person and okay that's that's other
thing you need to know is in order to
get the picture of the person you have
to look in the properties of the entity
and and find how to get the picture of
this person okay maybe maybe I can start
doing it now what do we have we see that
30 minutes 25 minutes are we left with a
little bit a little bit and we start
doing things that truly learn after you
classify and thing like that and that
some some of you might have come for
that and the next two example but
classifying predictor yeah you see how
was hockey gender class
gender classify a mango viral as well
because since it might be wrong ten
percent of the time before we make fun
of each other
which works with me okay let's try it so
how do we do that again a form function
so we can take the form function before
let's be lazy never killed anyone okay
so i take the winner of before and how
do i change that instead of calling it
first i will call it picture and here
the interpretation will be image okay so
it will go as image object in the wolfyn
language once it has been interpreted so
then the argument is picture here right
and i want to apply the classifying
notable person on this picture so i will
remove this function have to keep the a
person that's what you know tell that
it's a pure function so classify notable
person come a picture okay this would
return so entity and i put PNG to have
no problem of formatting to let
rasterize convert to an image and
display the image it would be to be
nicer and but I don't just want the
notable person I also want my picture so
i will put ash picture here so i just
put a list I don't try to do something
fancy with row or whatever I just put a
list and then we also want the picture
of the notable person all right so
that's where we need to get in property
so since we're going to use these things
twice ok now let's first get the
property so what's famous person
okay cool so then I can look at I wish I
was classified as the incident never
happened and then properties and we look
in the properties it as one for pictures
I think there is otherwise image image
Pam let's see if it works for sit down
right I guess images yeah can I look
like a movie and ok so now now this will
be entities so here we'll just do a
module to create a viable okay so okay
as soon as you start doing module and
stuff go into you know develop code cell
it's much nicer so then i will do a bit
of formatting put module here i will put
so this will be called entity and it is
the return by the classifier so and then
i will compute what this entity is okay
yeah I other entity and so I have to put
ok to close the modules please make a
big pure function all right and then I
will show my picture then the entity and
then the picture of the entity so I just
do like this image ego I think this
should okay minus the bugs this should
work and export all that to PNG then I
to be easier it pretty sure it would
work like this let me formats up so you
three argument so I put them like this
anyway okay here is a form and let's
cloud deploy it
cloud deploy and i deploy the foam and i
will put permissions to public so i can
try on my cell phone i will also bring
to a viable it's deployed and all right
let's URL shortener and actually
everybody can use that one but ok let me
try first before exclaiming let's try
like this it is fun it's working ok and
i can browse a picture and actually i
might have a picture of me so I can try
yes sing head is a picture of me I hope
it is all right oh I'm John Krasinski
again ok it's either Pacquiao Kaczynski
depending on the beard ok so it is here
is a is the app I didn't know what this
guy was before to time out of three team
anyway and so the URL shortener and so
you can try on your on your phone and ok
now I knew it works you can all use this
one since I put permissions to public
nice deploy it's a website you can all
use it you can all you know tell your
friends if maybe people use it I might
put an ad on it and get a bit of money
magic please spread the world in the web
so but then I have to type so i don't
think i need to put HTTP so just wolfe
dot a.m. it's always the same for the
reduced URL and then it's some kind of 7
f s I t.s
RF okay
what is it okay the network is indeed
very bad did you manage to make it work
yeah with this address I mean it for
yours it was ok yes ok good so it worked
and I don't know if you can I can show
you I mean you won't see so maybe I can
do its current image now is dynamic now
it's a trick to do video and I'm going
to put that so ah yeah what oh it's must
be where is it black you put a right or
something ok so it looks like this ok
and you're a button and you can click
and then you can do a selfie and no this
is not picture of you ok all right so
like this I agree and I do submit click
Submit ok it's submitted and
super bad happen maybe she's just better
like this actually I don't know it's
just slow it's ridiculous it's it's to
upload the picture I'm going to remove
the Wi-Fi and just go on the i'm going
to remove the Wi-Fi and just go on the
all right okay I went on the mobile
Internet I think it's going to be better
under Wi-Fi all right and as you can see
I'm again John Krasinski so it's kind of
consistent nothing is kind of cool I
mean to be able to do something like
that just in in few lines and honestly
something that people will actually like
to try and I like to try to try it okay
cool why you a good Oh guy oh yeah it
happens sometimes yeah whoo ok John
Munson Wow the Pope ok ok we should have
done some things that your app and send
an email to us yeah oh yeah you could
combine oh actually that was a anyway
yeah you could do like picture and this
one if you want to do image collage it's
another image collage and it will you
know return something you next to the
other one or you cannot mean a lesson to
it but you can also since now we have we
have we have linked toward you know like
the being API for images for example you
can get 5 image of the guy and putting
them in all the girl in the also
celebrity and a plume together I mean
you can do all sort of things
can be fun and make it look nice and
making like some people like they're not
the way there was for student from
Michigan University that you might have
seen gave talk in this room and another
one that won many a curtain and they
just use our technology and it looks
very nice like it's a nice website and
put a good background a good thing
doesn't look like of course just a
stupid list that returns and so you can
play with that and and if it's look good
I'm ready to bed that you you know it
will spread it was spread all right so
anyone it's almost the last one we have
two more and i will talk about one but
you won't do it as an exercise so one is
about finding which color where is the
main color in a picture but finding in a
intelligible way this is what
intelligible way it shouldn't say RGB
color 1.3 3.5 or whatever ok because
this is not something a human can
understand so it has to say it's black
it's white it's red it's blue ok and
from a picture and I mean I can imagine
does is it's pretty easy to do but
there's many application for that like
somebody that i colorblind and you know
you want to put some some things in the
morning and but then it's just our TV
yes exactly exactly sideways with our GV
but and the person can take a tiny cell
phone you know and and take picture or
maybe somebody blinds but that you left
to speak of course and it says blue red
and then it can you know
when he is buying because I guess yeah
the clothes you know you know the color
they have but when its buying your
clothes
all rights okay so the idea is to take a
picture find the dominant color in this
picture and then convert this dominant
color to to a label and for that you
will need to use machine learning it
sounds like a stupid thing and you may
say why why do I need machine learning
for that but if you think about it it'll
be it like what is what is red what is
purple what is you know what is the
definition of these things if you have a
nice mathematical definition for these
things if i can give you three numbers
of RGB and it tell me earlier this is
purple right you could use it you have a
bunch of aristocratic it's more
complicated that like there's some some
boundaries in this free space that are
nonlinear and so I mean you could be an
expert in color and maybe write a code
for that like a classic code but since
i'm not an expert in color i should ask
the image people maybe there will be a
good challenge try to do that actually
without machine learning so when one
thing to do so just to give you a leader
is that you have to get examples so you
know the first first youtube user
ontology define the colors that we want
to classify okay let's do that together
because otherwise so the color colors
okay it's a guide there and you see it
as name colors so we're going to use
this name colors okay so for example let
me see this let me reduce the screen
let's do the ontology right now
web column strings what is that what do
i type okay well let's do like this so
let's do okay so if I tap red is
actually represent the red so it's RGB
underneath you see RGB color so this one
will be the value red okay it should be
a first example let's construct the
other one the other one so let's do grin
so basically I mean basically it's just
doing that grin and then what is that
blue blue ok so I'm concerning data set
and black goes to black and okay not
very efficient what I do but can I do
this without typing everything yeah but
look at what it looks like ok at least I
can do some you know at least i will
copy all this like this no pink purple
and when do we have from yellow to we
had black so white ok let's do that I
will avoid i will have gray gray son
okay i want to own at least okay my
problem is to get the list because once
indeed I can do two strings no it will
convert to algae be so to do that yeah
but for a list of strings this will
evaluate so I we have to do an old let's
try gesture on this one I will have to
do old and we have to map at level two
a little too
and then I can an old and it should work
okay what we actually can't evaluate the
black before ok that's ridiculous
there's not enough let's do it we do by
hand I don't care you don't have time if
there was one hundred of course that
won't be the same business but I mean
unless you have an ID right now
yeah okay I'm over so i guess i will do
it because my toy 25 yeah okay i will do
it so yeah logos to yellow okay that's
our training set so we could do just one
element per class but machine learning
is quite bad i mean automatic machine
learning is quite bad if you have a tank
data set and one element per class it
will be hard because if you have time to
cross validate because it will use a
training set and a test set and if one
element in the training set it cannot be
in the test set so it will learn the
yellow and then you ask orange and of
course if we get wrong yeah
could have said that earlier all right
but are they oh nice okay okay that's a
bit too much for our thing but maybe we
yeah well maybe we try just this one I'm
almost over and then we can do the cool
one but it's true that's great i mean
with that you can actually do okay okay
this one is done that's the data set
training set so normally you should do
add more examples so it way to do that
is that you would do modification we do
random colors and will you curate all
that is ready this blue this is you know
let your choice and when you have that
you can you learn in classify I don't
have time to create extra color so i
will just classify like that but I won't
let the classify be automatic because it
would be too bad because it won't be
able to do training set and test set
with example of the same class in both
data set so so here I will just do
classify and of the training and i will
just put a method in order for it not to
try to do this cross validation thing so
I just put nearest neighbors and and ok
and let's actually put this one that is
not one of the color of our training set
and see what it says it says it's brown
that's really weird that's really weird
okay what was wrong here you had a
classified information I mean okay when
you have tiny the set like that it's
it's always a problem you have all wrong
things that happen so it's a good that's
weird yes neighbors there is not good
enough yeah you had to add more more
more data so I mean this one okay this
one should be blue brown ok I'm going to
look at the probabilities oh wait a
classified with with the head so add RGB
okay okay so yes yes so I will training
all one
it to be equal to and I will remove the
ad so it will be all what do I do
reference map no but if I if I do yeah
ok this would work ok ok ok ok so we
have our new training sets like this oh
we're white is one that's really but
then but I want I want to lgb thing so
what is the thing ok so yeah this is
list of all yeah and we will we will
color converted what's wrong what right
no no that oh yeah of course of course
of course of course of course of course
ok ok ok good perfect perfect it works
then we do classified training yes
neighbors and let's look at this one oh
dear no no I didn't do it this blue
violet blue violet is okay of course i
have to do color convert as well as we
have to do the same business and list
and click convert because we will use it
like this any so that's interesting any
transformation that you do to your
training set you have to do it to your
test set so you have to keep this this
thing ok so it will be cooler convert
and then it would be list at at and here
purple yeah ok let's deploy it let's try
it and ok 44 picture now what you can do
is we need to have doping
color of the picture so this is pretty
easy to do so let's get an image what
there's a color okay all right
hmm anyway so you can do you can do
dominant colors and and I will put 1 12
so dominant color and it's this stuff
and then I can actually try it right now
What did he say for that and it says
gray okay okay i guess some kind of
direct gray and let's deploy all that so
now it's going to be form function okay
this will put image image and it will be
interpreted as we call it picture like
like before now this is an image i can
do dominant colors of this image and
take the first one okay i have the color
i will use a module like before I don't
have time to use a code sale so i will
just up module and this will be cool
color it's important to put variables I
know that steven enjoys not using
variables anywhere but is wrong you have
to put variables otherwise you don't
understand what's going on we put a name
so you can the name you know what's
going on right anyway so color and now
this color we're going to apply our
function there and by the way it is a
picture this is ash picture and then I
will color convert to our color and
where does the color here okay what's
going on this is a form function a
percent ok I think I think that's it
right do you mean color you get the
first one then you when you see you can
see where when it's not in a hotel you
should really do that function first
argument the picture give an image then
module i will do i dint a shin like this
this is seed should grab from what it
has before and all right and what do we
do now it will just return a name right
we'll just return the string so we don't
have to do PNG a third argument we can
just let it like this and okay that's a
form function i will name it form and I
could try it but let's deploy it
directly cloud deploy form will also put
everything public now let's see cloud
object we call it C is a classifier that
I should have named better but ok URL
shorten of ok and I'm going to try it
straight away it's almost the same as
before who
so it is oh ok wolf's not here you can
try it as well it's public 7 ft
ft j why jhb be okay okay
so straight
alright so okay I'm in the morning and
I'm color blind and what oh do it better
I bet we won't risky no I'm kidding I
want it to work ok that's a picture and
I say okay and I click Submit let's see
the queen is big yellow I don't know not
be happy with yellow as well come on
okay I guess okay maybe I don't know the
resolution that is try to send my
actually my way okay let me press submit
again yeah my phone internet is actually
quite bad as well so does anyone have a
good phone and put the URL and want to
try it which is probably yeah you right
but I don't know I don't know I don't
know actually if it sends directly right
here okay as we can up
camera out okay I'm gonna take a picture
taking a picture all right and now
submit
what time is it oh we're a bit over a
bit over time so maybe let's just finish
this one and uh and then the next one
you can do it for yourself is you can
you keep it a data to get some some some
text and do a classifier with text so
you get a bunch of I'm going to get the
biology page remember maybe the fixed
page and maybe this will be the science
and then you get I don't know the Barack
Obama page and then my cane and you
create that to have the politic topic
and you do a bunch of them and you see
and you see what's happening okay my
internet is not good enough to send the
picture which actually should just
change the resolution of the picture
when I do it okay let's do it again up
camera and here my sitting maybe I
shouldn't lose the time with that but if
someone has a thing that works maybe
they can show show everyone I can I can
I take on droid is such a bad software
okay okay i can i can just show you
something then that we lose two minutes
or 5 or 10 but but it's going to be fun
so it's it's something is an application
that learns how long you're going to
wait in a line so it's a restaurant that
would use an application like that I
mean as you know in the US they always
make you wait in a line and so so here I
do cloud put to the spoon association
that would be metastructure byzantine my
cue this is a training said that i
generated myself so you can see that as
a pass data and and i also put this
training set in a cloud object so now
I've look you somewhere look at objects
somewhere I'm going to do a form and in
order to add somebody to the queue ok so
this form in from function that has a
bunch of things you can put a phone
number things like that this is not
required the phone number and what it
does is that it gets the queue and it
adds somebody to the queue and you put
it be put back the queue ok so this is a
forum at forum to add stuff so let's do
it i'm going to add someone so 2222 ok
so i add the bub bub is with three
persons ok and i submit and it's add
somebody and I'm gonna add somebody at
least that is five person and I don't
bother to put the phone numbers but you
could as well in the application could
maybe send a SMS or something and then
you have a what what's another name
Claire it's my sister and Claire is with
a boyfriend she's single by the way
and.and okay now let's look at the Q and
so I do to glance at it that I said just
to visualize so okay other persons it
stalled the day so we're thursday so
it's all the things that of course the
thing knows you just have to do now and
a name is to all the time I just story
in unix time okay a phone number there's
nothing this is a history so this is a
something as a cue go along each time I
updated history like when was this
person waiting when there's only one
person in front of two person in front
of blah blah blah this I have dropped
foam so the form to drop somebody from
the queue and when it drops it has a
bunch of things so I mean that's when I
exercise that I couldn't I've done here
is that it compute the time that if
effectively the group effectively waited
and then it add that the training set so
this is an application that continuously
learn okay you gotta to a training set
and then a perform predict on this
training set and that's one of the
advantage we have something that is
completely automatic that you don't know
what you're going to have you create an
application may be a restaurant we have
a lot of people maybe that will have
some other characteristics to the people
like the group maybe they will have some
other things like I don't know we can
characteristics that would add the color
doesn't need to know about that just you
predict and it will predict always
something supposedly decent and then I
put this this platform I put this
predictor somewhere and okay let's let's
look at the drop form let's remove
somebody and okay let's remove we do we
remove remove Claire she just broke up
and next free anyway so this you remove
somebody from the from the queue and I
could look at the queue again and
normally player should be removed and
the training set will be augmented if we
look at the training set we should have
okay guys go ahead and do any sect of
one more one more example and and then
and then you can visualize the object so
this is this is a URL that the user
would have and what it does is that it
gets the predictor it does prediction on
the
like you know how long have you been
waiting all many people you are
basically and you conduct to so go and
whatever any plots a nice distribution
it's a very geeky that tells you you
distribution on how long you expect it
to wait so Bob is supposed to wait three
minutes that's the most likely value but
you see that it's actually quite wide
and if you actually end up spending 10
minutes he might not be ale to mattress
that you see there were some probability
that you would wait in it and this might
seem stupid you might say oh we don't
know this table in the restaurant is the
table of three percent five person you
know like you don't need to know because
the thing learns you know the thing
learned that when there's somebody with
only two persons it happened that at
this time when you two persons it goes
quite fast so you can improve but even
without any assumption of that
restaurant I didn't try it on a true
restaurant but I'm ready to bet that it
does a pretty good job probably better
and this you should compare because you
can ask them and they give you a time
and you compare you can do a control
experiment to see the time they give and
they know perfectly the restaurant that
every day is better than learner and I'm
ready to bed that the learner maybe not
a lot of money but that's better than
the expert in the restaurant